I called
you because I wanted to apologize to you for one thing I'm
sorry I've caused you so much trouble until now What's changed I won't
help the d class move up anymore
That need has just disappeared  That's why
[music]
So from now on, I
'm going to be quiet I'm going to leave everything to Horikita and Hirata.
Didn't you hear me?
I told you that this is the last time I'll be contacting you.
Except for the emergency address for that purpose,
please erase it completely so as not to leave any evidence.I've
already deleted your contact information
.  No
matter what, I mean,
our relationship was originally cold,
but you didn't want to be used by me
.
[music]